[Music]
his great power
comes great responsibility
keep being a friendly neighborhood
spider-man
that's what we do
yeah it's what we do
all right let's do this
focus trust your tingle
i have the tingle thing just not for
brent
you are amazing thank you yeah will you
say it no i kind of needed to hear that
thank you
peter one
eight or two
you know three i love you guys
yes
we just had a little dance in the suit
yeah cuddle we had a cuddle the cobwebs
off a little bit for me
doing a photo shoot with
two lads in lycra
[Music]
[Music]
the suit can definitely be like a
challenge at times when you got to get
in the full thing um
but then like getting comfortable in it
there is something fun yeah it just
helps as an actor when you get in your
costume you begin to like feel it more
and embody it more and i'm still
processing it's all happening still i'm
catching up yeah this only just happened
but objectively you got pretty free
pretty quick oh yeah
that's true yeah you started to feel
pretty at home yeah i didn't start
awesome pretty quickly i did yeah i just
i have no explanation for it it just did
instinctual yeah it releases something
it just did it
[Music]
we're gonna lift you up on a cherry
picker and you're gonna jump off
how they became super villains it's just
so funny i fell into a super collider
gotta be careful where you fall
to work with them is honestly the
highlight of my career me and toby
arrived and all of their arms were just
open
[Music]
[Music]
red butterflies with toby and andrew
hoping they will sign up
[Music]
you